- All right, let's finish up
with one last story that
celebrates our love of reading.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
Everyone in our audience is
holding a book in their hands
and there's something about
a real book, not a tablet,
that makes reading that
much more enjoyable.
Don't you agree?
It's a real book.
It's tangible, it's nice.
It smells good, it's nice.
Every year though,
there are fewer librarians
working in public schools.
In fact, there are fewer
libraries in schools at all.
So a Nebraska nonprofit is
working to put physical books
in the hands of every school
kid whenever they want one.
It's called DIBS for Kids,
and it recently won an award
from the Library of Congress.
(imitating siren)
(audience cheering)
Here to explain,
let's say hi to Angie watching on KETV.
What's up, Angie?
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Kelly.
- Hello.
So this isn't a library.
Can you explain how it works?
- Yeah, so DIBS for Kids,
which stands for Delivering
Infinite Bookshelves for Kids,
provides high interest,
representative, diverse books
in elementary schools throughout Omaha.
We work with 5,000 students here.
And what we do, like you
can see in this picture,
students every day come
into their classroom
pick out a physical, tangible
book, take it home to read,
come back the next day,
check that book in,
pick out another book for themselves.
And that means that, you know,
the kids can discover the joy of reading.
They take home about three
books a week on average,
and we're just thrilled to be
on that reading journey with them.
- It's really incredible
what you're doing.
There's a lot of ground
to cover though, right?
- There is a significant
amount of ground to cover.
Like you said, libraries are
every year there's fewer,
but you know what?
We know that bringing
more books into classrooms
lets kids really experience
that joy of reading.
We know it helps kids gain
further reading proficiency,
get back up to grade level.
And so, really being able
to be in the classrooms
really helps DIBS and
those students specifically
can make up all of that ground.
And like I said,
we just are so thrilled to be able
to help all of those students
here in the Omaha community.
- Well, it's incredible.
It's amazing what you're
doing for all those kids.
Thank you so much, Angie.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(audience clapping)
- [Angie] Yeah, thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
- Absolutely, and that's not all, girl.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
instilling the love of reading
to all just like you
so they're giving DIBS for Kids $1,000.
How's that sound?
- Ah, thank you.
Thank you so much.
That's amazing.
We appreciate it.
- Absolutely, Angie.
Have a great day
and thank you to all of
our guests this hour.
Jane Fonda, Candice Bergen, Diane Keaton,
Mary Steenburgen, and Caitlin Smith.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
maybe get lost in a book and
try and make the day better.